c'en est fini du cursus scolaire
français dans les écoles algériennes la
chasse au double programme a été
annoncée en cette rentrée par le
ministère algérien de l'éducation dans
le viseur de l'exécutif les
établissements privés qui proposent aux
élèves de suivre le programme français
en plus voir à la place du programme
algérien la loi devra désormais être
appliquée strictoensu interdiction
d'utiliser les manuels autres que ceux
du programme officiel et respect des 5
heures de langues étrangères prévues par
le programme les directeurs des
établissements privés auraient même été
convoqués au ministère pour s'engager
par écrit à ne pas suivre le programme
français sous peine de poursuites pénale
quant au lycée international Alexandre
Dumas à Alger aussi appelé lycée
français il l'accueillera plus les
épreuves du baccalauréat les candidats
libres devront passer l'examen à
l'étranger prise de cours certaines
écoles ont dû fermer à peine la rentrée
entamée renvoyant chez eux les enfants
mon fils est à la maison je ne sais pas
quoi faire c'est une catastrophe
j'attends que l'école me propose un plan
B en réalité si les doubles programmes
avaient jusqu'à présent été toléré
beaucoup d'établissements privés opérait
déjà en dehors du cadre légal certaines
écoles n'en saignaient plus du tout le
programme algérien d'autres proposaient
un cursus francophone sur la base de
Manuel algérien traduit d'autres encore
déguisaient leur cursus sous la forme de
cours de soutien dispensés sur les
horaires de cours stigmatiser depuis
l'indépendance comme langue coloniale le
français accuse un recul tant à l'école
qu'à l'université il tend aujourd'hui à
être supplanté par l'Anglais devenu
cette année la langue d'enseignement à
l'université sur ordre du président
algérien Abdelmadjid teboun
[Musique]